اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
المياه في نوفا تنحسر لكن الفيضان يبقى
خارج السيطره وروسيا تعلن حاله الطوارئ في
خرسون
بعد مؤشرات غربيه على انطلاق شراره الهجوم
المضاد روسيا تؤكد ان اوكرانيا بدات
هجومها بالفعل
ملفات اقليميه ودوليه على اجنده مباحثات
بلنكن في السعوديه و واشنطن تؤكد قوه
العلاقه بين البلدين
وفي نشرتنا ايضا تقرير خاص الفقر الجوع
وانعدام الامن ثلاثيه تدفع الافغان الى
العيش في الكهوف
صباح الخير في حرب اوكرانيا مشاهدينا
تتركز الانظار الان على منطقه خرسون
وتحديدا بعد استهداف سد نوفا كخوفكا
المشهد من الاعلى يبدو كارثيا قرى باكملها
غمرت تحت الماء عمليات الاجلاء مستمره لكن
اداره مدينه نوفاكا خوف كالتي عينتها
روسيا اكدت ان منسوب المياه في المدينه
بدا يتراجع صباح اليوم بعد دمار السد وفي
بيان لها قالت اناء منسوب المياه في
الشوارع التي غمرتها المياه بدا في
الانحسار الخسائر كبيره فعل الضفه الشرقيه
من نهر دريم برو غمر الف او غمر الفيضان
اكثر من 1800 منزل بحسب الاداره العسكريه
لخرسون طبعا الاداره واقرت ايضا بان شده
الفيضانات اخذه بالتناقص فعليا لكنها خارج
السيطره حيث اعلنت السلطات الروسيه حاله
الطوارئ في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها في
خرسون
[موسيقى]
ورغم عمليات الاجلاء فور تدمير سبنوبك
خوفكا اعلن رئيس بلديه نوبكا خوفك الموالي
لروسيا فقدان سبعه اشخاص على الاقل بعدما
غمرت مياه السد العديد من القرى على نهر
النيبرو مشيرا الى ان مستوى المياه ارتفع
في المناطق السكنيه لاكثر من ثلاثه امتار
من موسكو معنا مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم
اهلا بك معنا كاتيا بدايه وحول هذا السد
الذي تدمر وادى الى كارثه بيئيه كما يتوقع
بعض المحللين هل من ردود فعل روسيه جديده
هل من تصريحات خرجت من الجانب الروسي حول
ذلك
مرحبا فاطمه
ورفضت جميع الاتهامات التي تم توجيهها
اليها بانها هي التي تقف خلف تفجير هذا
السد كان
قال ان اوكرانيا هي من تقف خلف هذه
العمليه التي وصفتها الخارجيه الروسيه
ايضا بانها عمليه ارهابيه ارتكبتها القوات
الاوكرانيه كانت روسيا قد دعت الى جلسه
طارئه لانقاذ لعقد جلسه طارئه لمجلس الامن
والذي تحدث فيها مندوب روسيا بان اوكرانيا
هي ارتكبت عملا ارهابيا كانت قد خططت له
منذ فتره طويله لذلك هو كان في حيره كما
تحدث من امره بسبب عدم وجود ادانه من قبل
الامانه العامه لمجلس الامن الدولي طبعا
حقيقه فاطمه كان هناك طبعا من الجانب
الميداني وابن الجانب اوضاع هناك في
في المنطقه كما تحدث
المواليون لروسيا بانها ان المياه غمرت
نحو
2700 منزل يقع على دفعه نهر النيبرو
بالاضافه لذلك طبعا المنطقه السكان
المنطقه يبلغ عددهم الى نحو 40 الف مواطن
سيتم اجلاؤهم تم اجراء نحو 1700 كما تحدثت
السلطات المواليه الى اماكن سكن مؤقته تم
تخصيصها من الجانب طبعا في هناك في
المنطقه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا والجانب
المهالي لروسيا تم تخصيص منطقه نحو 400
مكان لاستيعاب هؤلاء السكان الذين سيتم
اجلاؤهم طبعا فيما بعد عن المنطقه
بالاضافه الى وجود طبعا سبع اشخاص تم
فقدانهم كما تحدثت ايضا السلطات المواليه
واريد ايضا ان اشير الى محطه زفروجيا هي
كما تحدث خبراء انها تعمل حتى الان بشكلها
طبيعي على الرغم من انخفاض مستوى المياه
لديها بعد تفجير السد فاطمه نعم تقول عن
مسؤول محلي بحسب العاجل امامنا كاتيا بان
100 شخص عالق في نوفاكوفك حتى الان
ينتظرون الاجلاء شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمى
نحو 200 كيلومتر هي المسافه بين سد نوفاكا
خوفكا ومحطه زابوريجيا التي احاطت بها
مخاطر كبيره بعد تفجير السد لكن يقع السد
كما محطه النوويه على نهر النيبرو الذي
يزود المحطه الاكبر في اوروبا بالمياه
لتبريد ما فعلت
السته لكن اين الخطر مع الفيضان الذي نجم
عن تدمير السد انخفض مستوى البحيره
المخصصه لتدمير قلب المفاعل او تبريد قلب
المفاعل المعلم المعلومات تشير الى ان
المنسوب انخفض حتى الان نحو مترين ونصف
والتوقعات تشير الى ان الى ان يصل الى
سبعه امتار هذا الانخفاض وهذا يعني تاثير
مباشر وخطير على المحطه لان نقص المياه
اللازمه للتبريد لفتره طويله يمكن ان يؤدي
الى تعطل مولدات الديزل في حالات الطوارئ
لم يمضي يومنا على تحذير يامن عام الوكاله
الدوريه للطاقه الذريه رفيال جروستي من ان
القتال المتزايد في محيطي منشاه يجعل
تامينها مهمه صعبه حتى استفاق غروسيا على
خبر تفجير سد نوفا الذي يؤمنوا مياه
التبريد للمنشاه الذي سارع لاحاطه مجلس
المحافظين بطبيعات ذلك على المنشاه
النوويه قال ان مياه التبريد من خزان السد
ستتوقف بعد ايام ولكنه تحدث عن بدائل
تؤمنها بوركو تبريد مجاوره للمنشاه
النوويه تكفي لبضعه اشهر
من الضروري ان تظل بروكو التبريد سليمه
يجب الا يحصل اي شيء يعرض سلامتها للخطر
لذا ادعو جميع الاطراف الى ضمان عدم
القيام بشيء لتقويض سلامتها العواقب يمكن
ان تكون خطيره
السفير الروسي منوف الذي اراد الاحتفال
بيوم اللغه الروسيه في مقر الامم المتحده
في فيينا وجد نفسه مضطرا للتحدث
بالانجليزيه وليس بالروسيه كما اراد للرد
على دعوه كروستي جميع الاطراف تامين برك
التبريد
لا يحتاج الامر قول ان كل الجهود ستبذل
لتامين الامن النووي والقول ان روسيا تعرض
منشاتها النوويه للخطر هو امر سخيف نحن
اسسنا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كنا
من الدول المؤسسه وبالطبع دائما نتعاون مع
الوكاله ونتوقع ان تتعاون الوكاله معنا
وفيما تراقب الوكاله تاثير تفجير السد على
محطه
دقيقه بدقيقه كما قال جروستي تحشد
اوكرانيا هنا ايضا داخل مجلس المحافظين
لردود دوليه تدين روسيا التي تتهمها
بتدمير السد فور انتهاء اعمال مجلس
المحافظين هنا نهايه هذا الاسبوع سيتوجه
جراستي فورا الى منشاه زابوريجيا في زياره
كان مخططا لها مسبقا ولكنها الان باتت
اساسيه كما قال في محاوله لاحتوائ اي
تصعيدا محتمل يخشى ان يتسبب بكارثه
النوويه را غده بهنام العربيه
للطاقه الذريه سابقا الدكتور يسري ابو
شادي اهلا بك معنا دكتور بدايه لنتحدث عن
الانخفاض المقلق لمنسوب المياه في نهر
دنيبرو وفي البحيره التي تساهم في تبريد
المفاعلات النوويه في زبوريجيا ما تاثير
ذلك يعني الى اي مدى هو خطير
دكتور هل تسمعني شمعه كويسه
دكتور اسالك عن مدى تاثير انخفاض منسوب
المياه على المفاعل النوويه والخطر الذي
يمكن ان يحيط بذلك
واطمن العالم ابن العمليه ما فيهاش خطوره
كبيره لان مفاعلات جابولوجيا السته
التصميم بتاعهم في حاله التبريد تصميم خاص
ما بيعتمدش بشكل اساسي على
البحيرات
المخزنه من السد ولا على انهار ولا على
محيطات او بحار او زي بعض المحطات الاخرى
اذا هو دايره التبريد الثالثه اللي هي
لابد منها لتبريد وتكثيف البخار في الاخر
دي في حاله زبروجيا بصوره خاصه بتبرد
بدايره شبه مغلقه يعني ايه يعني
زابولوجيا فيها اثنين ابراج تبريد ضخمين
جدا
وفيها بحيره
شبه خاصه بها هي بس غير الخزان بتاع السد
وبالتالي التبريد بيتم بشكل شبه مغلق من
الميه دي هي اذا كان في حاجه للتبريد
الفرق الوحيد بس انه بياخده تعويض حاجه
اقل من 10% بسبب ان البخار بعض المياه
بتضيع في التبخير وغيره ده ممكن ياخدوه
بقى من الخزان السد او حاجه اذا الحاجه
الى يعني حتى البحيره الاصطناعيه التي
نتحدث عنها تاخذ المياه او يصب فيها
المياه من نهر النيبرو الذي ايضا يتاثر من
هذا السد صحيح الى كميه الميه التعويضيه
كميه محدوده للغايه اقل من يمكن 10% من
دائره تبريد الميه المطلوبه للمفاعل بمعنى
اخر بس عشان اوضح المفاعلات العاديه زي
مثلا مفاعلات الضبعه ولا مفاعلات حتى
الامارات ولا حاجه دول بيعتمدوا اساسا
تبريدهم على دائره مفتوحه باخد الميه من
البحر
تبرد وتسخن الميه دي وارجع ارميها في
البحر تاني دايره مختلفه ما باخدش الميه
من بحيره الخزان وببرد وارجع ارميها تاني
لا انا باخدها من
بحيره ويعيد استخدامها نفسها وعيد برافو
وعيد استخدام عن طريق ابراج التبريد
القويه جدا دي وترجع زائد بقى في نقطه
تانيه مهمه جدا ان الست المفاعلات دول
اصلا خمسه منهم مغلقين بقى لهم شهور عديده
وبالتالي هم بيسموها في داون يعني مش
محتاجين تقريبا لتبريد الا ضعيف للغايه
لان هم خلاص بردوا ومش والمفاعلات بتاعتهم
مقفوله مفعل واحد بس مش شغال برده لكن
من شهر او شهرين ده هو اللي لسه محتاج
لبعض التبريد ومع الوقت طبعا هينتهي اذا
ذابولوجيا من ناحيه احتياجها لموضوع مياه
للتبريد محدوده للغايه زائد ما ننساش ان
السد نفسه
ده هو يعني الحقيقه لما اجي اقارنه مثلا
بحاجه زيد العالي اقول لا ده ده بالنسبه
له صغير سجل علي الكباشي بتاعته 7000 مره
قد الخزان ده يعني مش مش الاساسي قوي قوي
في المنطقه دي كميه ولكن يعني هي ليست
الخطر الوحيد ربما دكتور ابقى معي لاعود
اليك ونتحدث عن مخاطر كثيره تترتب على هذه
الكارثه وتاثيرها قد يستغرق شهور وربما
سنوات فتدمير اجساد قد يغير ان نضمن
البيئيه الى الابد وذلك بحسب واشنطن بوست
الصحيفه حذرت نقلا عن خبراء من ان تدمير
السد الرئيسي ومحطه الطاقه الكهرومائيه قد
يؤدي الى تجفيف المنطقه الزراعيه الغنيه
في جنوب اوكرانيا واكتساح الملوثات في
المجاري المائيه وتقلب النظم البيئيه التي
نش حول الخزان الضخم والذي تتدفق مياهه
الان بسرعه ما يعرض المجتمعات التي تعتمد
على المياه للشرب وزراعه المحاصيل تعرضهم
الى خطر كبير الخطر قد يكون ابعد من ذلك
ويصل الى اعاده تشكيل خريطه اوكرانيا
ومياهها وسبل عيشها نعود الى ضيفنا من
فيينا رئيس قسم ضمانات وكبير مفتشين وكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه سابقا الدكتور يسري
ابو شادي دكتور يعني بعيد عن محطه
زابوريجا والتي فهمنا منك مدى خطورتها من
عدمه ولكن لنتحدث عن التاثير البيئي
لانفجار هذا السد يعني الى اي مدى هو فعلا
كارثي خصوصا انه فعلا بدا بالانحسار ولكنه
مستمر وخارج السيطره وطويل الامد يعني قد
نرى اثاره ممتده الى سنوات
ده حقيقي لا وبصوره خاصه جنوب بالسد ليه
لان السد بيحجز الميه من الشمال الميه
بتيجي من الشغل عشان كده البحيره بحيرات
الخزان بتاعته موجوده في الشمال والجنوب
هو ده المستوى الميه المنخفض المستوى
الميه اللي في الجنوب ده اتغرق
والمناطق القرى عشان كده الروس بيهجروا
دلوقتي الناس اللي ساكنين في الجنوب اللي
هي المنطقه اللي محتلها روسيا زائد في
صوره كبيره قوي يمكن حضرتك ما قلتهاش
الروس كانوا زارعين كميه ضخمه جدا من
الالغام
واعتقد الروس النهارده صرحوا وقالوا
الالغام دي اتحركت وما بقيناش عارفين
اماكنها فين
صحيح ودي خطر جسيم وبالذات على السكان
اللي في الجنوب الجنوب الخزان دي يعني
زائد بقى ان في جزيره القرم كلها يمكن 80
90% من المياه بتاعتها ومياه شرب معتمده
على ميه الخزان ده وعلى هذا الخزان
بالتالي ما مدى خطوره دخول السدود هذه
دكتور في سياق الحرب
مع الاسف كله بسبب الحرب المؤشفه دي
طيب دكتور فجر ده بيتجاهل كمان كل الحقوق
الانسانيه لناس المناطق دي اذا دخول
السدود وتفجير السدود وتدميرها يعني يؤثر
بشكل سيء جدا ليس فقط على الامن البيئي
والامن
الحياتي والمعيشي على الناس ولكن ايضا على
الوجود
لجزيره القرم كما تفضل دكتور كذلك على
الاسلحه وعلى الالغام التي كانت مختبئه
والان لا يعلمون اين هي وكيف يتداركون ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك من رئيس قسم ضمانات وكبير
مفتشين الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
سابقا دكتور يسري ابو شادي
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره مشاهدينا من
مدينه نوفاكا خوفكا وكيف تغمر المياه
المنازل فيما تستمر عمليات اجلاء السكان
نتابع
ومن اطراف هذه المدينه تحديدا مدينه
نوفاكخوف كي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
رائد الاغبر اهلا بك معنا رائد انت تتواجد
على اطراف هذه المدينه بالتالي انقل لنا
المستجدات حول الاضرار وحول الوضع اثراء
هذه الكارثه
نعم فاطمه نحن يعني
نقيم في مدينه ميليتوبل الان اقرب المدن
الى نوفيكا التي تشهد تطورات وعمليات
اجلاء من قبل وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه التي
تعمل باستمرار من اجل اجلاء كل المواطنين
المتضررين الحديث عن 1500 مواطن تضرر وتم
اجلائهم منهم يعني سبعه مفقودين حتى الان
داخل مدينه نوفيكا خوف كحسب السلطات
المحليه 17
يعني مصابا تم انقاذهم من اعلى اسطح
المنازل والبيوت كانوا يعني الى اللحظات
الاخيره كانوا يمكن ان يفقدوا حياتهم
بالفعل المنطقه ما زالت يعني متضرره بشكل
كبير منسوب المياه انخفض ليله امس الى بعد
ان ارتفع في النهر
لمستوى كبير جدا الى نسبه 12 ونصف متر نزل
35 سم وبدا بالانخفاض تدريجيا كمؤشر على
انتهاء الازمه لكن يعني حديث السلطات
والمصريين بان الازمه تحتاج ثلاثه ايام
لانخفاض المياه وعودتها الى منصوبه
الطبيعي التبادل بالاتهامات بضرب هذا
الجسر من قبل الجانب الاوكراني والروسي هو
حديث
الشارع حيث ان الطرفين يظهر يظهر يظهران
فيديوهات لضرب الجسر الطرف الاوكراني يظهر
فيديو تفجير لجسر الطرف الروسي يظهر فيديو
استهداف وقصف للجسم
وزير الدفاع الروسي قال بان روسيا ليست
لديها اي مصلحه
باستهداف هذا الجسر او بتفجيره لان هذا
يؤدي او يؤدى الى تدهور الاوضاع عند
القوات الروسيه حيث الخنادق التي غمرتها
المياه الخنادق الدفاعيه والغاء الالغام
التي كانت منتشره على ضفه النهر الشماليه
منطقه خرسون والتي انجرفت واصبحت غير
معلوم مكانها وهي تضر بتحرك القوات
وتنقلاته وكذلك بالمواطنين مقاطعه خرسون
اعلنت التعبئه العامه بالفئه عفوا
اعلنت الطوارئ حاله الطوارئ العامه وما
زالت عمليات الاجلاء تجري عفوا ما زالت
عمليات الاجراء الاجراء تجري حيث تنقل
يعني ينقل
المواطنين الى المناطق الاكثر امنا الحديث
عن 500
منزل او 600 منزل تم يعني اغراق او تم
اغراقهم او غرقوا بالكامل الحديث عن مقبره
جثث الموتى طافت فوق سطح المياه الحديث عن
يعني بالفعل ضرر كبير انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي والاتصالات في المنطقه بشكل
كامل وربما يكون تكون اعداد يعني
المفقودين اكبر مع ساعات النهار القادمه
ربما نستطيع الدخول الى المنطقه في
الساعات القريبه فاطمه
نعم وسنترقب ونبقى معك في كل جديد رائد
بكل تاكيد شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه ميلتوبل
مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
[موسيقى]
على ماتوا هجوم مضاد طالما توعدت به
اوكرانيا
اقترب حيث اكد مجلس الامن الروسي قبل قليل
المؤشرات تؤكد ان اوكرانيا بدات هجومها
المضاد سبق ذلك ان اكد وزير الدفاع الروسي
باشرت فعلا بشن ما هددت به خلال الفتره
الماضيه وفي غضون ثلاثه ايام نفذت
اوكرانيا وعيدها على سبع اتجاهات من
الجبهه وذلك باستخدام خمسه الويه ولكن كل
محاولات الجيش الاوكراني في الهجوم باءت
بالفشل هكذا يقول شويجو الذي اوضح ان
الهجوم الذي هددوا به عاد اليهم بخسائر
كبيره علامات بدات بالظهور مع ترجيح
المسؤولين الغربيين ان شراره الهجوم
المضاد قد اشتعلت تدريجيا وملاحظتهم ان
قتالا اعنف من ضيقه بل خلال 48 ساعه شرق
اوكرانيا والهدف براي المسؤولين هو
اكتشافه نقاط الضعف الروسيه قبل شن
الهجمات القاضيه
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
الاشتباكات تتجدد في ام درمان وازمه
المستشفيات تتفاقم
احييكم من جديد مجتمع ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز مع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في جده واستعرض
الجانبان العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
الصديقين كما استعرضا اوجه التعاون في
مختلف المجالات وسبل تعزيزها الى جانب
تطورات الاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه
والجهود المبذوله بشانها
صدر بيان من الخارجيه الامريكيه يؤكد قوه
العلاقه بين الرياض و واشنطن الممتده
لاكثر من 80 عاما واشارت الخارجيه في بيان
ان العمل على ضمان الامن الاقليمي يعد احد
اسس العلاقه مع السعوديه
العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه ثمانيه عقود
من الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين السعوديه
وامريكا
بحسب بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه فان
السعوديه والولايات المتحده تجمعهما علاقه
استراتيجيه ممتده لاكثر من 80 عاما حيث
يعد العمل على ضمان الامن الاقليمي احد
اسس العلاقه مع الرياض وتعزز العلاقه مع
الرياض امن الخليج والقدره على ردع اي
تهديد لامن المنطقه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هناك التزاما
بتعزيز الشراكه الامنيه مع الرياض عبر دعم
البنيه الدفاعيه الجويه والتدريبات
المشتركه وتعمل السعوديه والولايات
المتحده على حل ازمه السودان وحمايه
المدنيين وتمكين وصول المساعدات كما دعمت
السعوديه الجهود التي قامت بها الامم
المتحده في خفض التصعيد واحلال السلام في
اليمن
ورحبت الولايات المتحده بالخطوات التي
اتخذتها السعوديه لدعم اوكرانيا بما في
ذلك التعهد بتقديم مساعدات بقيمه 400
مليون دولار
معنى من واشنطن الباحث في الشؤون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
اهلا بك معنا سيد ايهاب بدايه في اي سياق
يمكن وضع هذه الزياره الامريكيه والزيارات
الامريكيه السابقه الحديثه بشكل عام خصوصا
واننا راينا بالامس ايضا زياره من الرئيس
الفنزويلي وهي دوله تشهد عقوبات امريكيه
عليها
نعم اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بالمشاهدين بدايه
فيما يتعلق بزياره الرئيس الفانزولي لا
اعتقد ان ذلك يؤثر على العلاقات الامريكيه
السعوديه بالشكل الذي ربما يتوقعه البعض
البعض لماذا لان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دوله كبيره لا تاتمر باوامر احد لا تبني
علاقاتها بناء على مطالب من دول اخرى
وانما تبني علاقاتها مع الدول الاخرى بناء
على المعطيات الاقليميه والدوليه
ورغبتها في احلال واستقرار
للامن والسلم العالميين وايضا طبقا
للمعطيات الاقتصاديه تبحث المملكه العربيه
السعوديه دائما عن علاقات قويه
وشراكات حقيقيه واستراتيجيه مع مختلف دول
العالم هذا جانب الجانب الاخر المتعلق
بالولايات المتحده وزياره لينكن
وتكثيف التعاون الامريكي السعودي خلال
الفتره الماضيه في عدد من المياه المجالات
وكان اخرها طبعا
مجال محاوله فض النزاع في السودان من خلال
الهدى المختلفه واستضافه المملكه
الاجتماعات جده بين المتنازعين في السودان
الولايات المتحده يعني نعود قليلا الى
الوراء مع بدايات حكم جو بايدن كانت لديها
رؤيه مختلفه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
كانت تعتقد انها من الممكن ان تملي عليها
بعض الشروط المتعلقه بالعلاقات الثنائيه
بين الجانبين ولكن سرعان المتحده من
السعوديه الان
عفوا لم اسمع السؤال ماذا تريد الولايات
المتحده من السعوديه الان خصوصا كما ذكرت
بانه في بدايه عهد بايدن يعني كانوا
يحاولون ان يجعلوا السعوديه منبوذه كما
كان يقول بايدن
صحيح صحيح اتفق مع حضرتك يعني الولايات
المتحده او اداره جو بايدن لنقل سرعان ما
اكتشفت حقيقه الامور وهي ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه دوله كبرى دوله ذات
علاقات وقدرات استراتيجيه هائله مع
اقليمها ومع دول العالم ولديها رؤيه واضحه
في مجالات مختلفه من بينها المجال الامني
والمجال الاستثماري والمجال للمجالات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه ومكافحه الارهاب الى
اخره فبدات العلاقات رويدا رويدا من جانب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعود الى
طبيعتها مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني
ما اقصده هنا ان المملكه لم تغير من
نسق وسياق علاقته مع الولايات المتحده بقى
الولايات المتحده هي التي غيرت سواء
يعني كما ذكرنا عهد بايدن في بدايته بعدم
الاعتناء بهذه العلاقه المهمه ومرورا
بادراك اهميه هذه العلاقه الى ان وصلنا
اليوم هناك تعاون في المجالات وشراكه
حقيقيه في مجال استفيد من وقتي معك قدر
الامكان اود ان افهم منك حل عدد من
الملفات الخلافيه الموجوده بين عدد من دول
المنطقه الى عادت العلاقات في المرحله
الحاليه على ما اعتقد الى وضعها الطبيعي
ادراكا من حكومه
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا يمكنها
ولذلك هي اخرت وضيعت من وجهه نظري تقريبا
عام في بدايه حكمها بسبب الافكار التي
كانت تدور في مخيله وعقليه الاداره
الامريكيه ادركت انها كلها كانت افكار
خاطئه ولا يمكن ان تطبق مع دوله كبرى بحجم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فعاده الولايات
المتحده مره اخرى الى حظيره العلاقات
الطبيعيه مع المملكه واعتقد هذا سيكون في
مصلحه الولايات المتحده قبل ان يكون في
مصلحه المملكه العربيه السعوديه تعلم كيف
تدير ملفاتها جيدا لديها علاقات قويه مع
دول الجوار في الفتره حتى اعدت علاقاتها
التي يعني على راس
اجنده الزياره الامريكيه برايك
المملكه تتعاون كل الدول في اطار دائما
تحقيق السلام وصولا للتنميه والرخاء
المطلوبه لكل دول المنطقه سيد ايهاب كنت
اسالك ولكن ربما لا يصلك صوتي كنت اسالك
عن ابرز الملفات التي تعتقد انها على راس
اجنده الزياره الامريكيه مع العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه
طبعا يعني هناك حديث دائم ومستمر عن
الشراكه الاقتصاديه والتجاريه وتعزيز
التعاون المشترك الى اخره لكن اذا ما
فصلنا اكثر هذه الملفات اولا سيكون هناك
دائما الملف الامني المتعلق بامن المنطقه
وسلامها لذلك تبحث الجانبان فيما يتعلق
بتعزيز التعاون في مكافحه الارهاب بكل
تاكيد خاصه ان هناك تحالف دولي ما زال
مستمرا
لهزيمه داعش منذ عام 2014 على ما تذكر او
2015 ومازال مستمره الى الان هذا جانب
الجانب الاخر طبعا الملف الاني والحالي
المتعلق
بالسودان والنزاع الدائره هناك بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع هذا جانب مهم جدا هناك
جهود مشتركه بين الجانبين تعزيز السلام
والامن الدوليين خاصه في منطقه مليئه
بالصراعات وبالنزاعات والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه تعد رمانه ميزان في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي اكيد هناك تباحث مشترك مع
الولايات المتحده في هذا الاطار في عدد من
الملفات يعني ملف ايران ملف سوريا ملف
اليمن ملفات مختلفه بكل تاكيد وادراكا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاهميه الدوري
السعودي اعتقد سيكون هناك انصاد جيد جدا
من اداره جو بايدن او منكن والمسؤولين في
الخارجيه الامريكيه الذين يقومون بهذه
الزياره للرؤيه السعوديه في هذه الملفات
المختلفه املا ان يكون هناك حلول ناجعه
وحقيقيه لهذه الملفات التي تؤرق الجميع
بما فيهم الولايات المتحده التي هي تسكن
في اخر العالم يعني
طيب سيدي ايهاب عباس
الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه والعلاقات
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من واشنطن
تواصل القوات الاسرائيليه عمليات الاقتحام
في اراضي الضفه الغربيه والقدس حيث اصيب
ثلاثه فلسطينيين بالرصاص في مخيم عقبه جبر
في اريحا بعد اقتحام اعداد كبيره من قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي لتلك المنطقه والمخيم
وشن حمله دهم وتفتيش
وتفتيش للمنازل حيث اندلعت اشتباكات واصيب
جدي اسرائيلي قبل ان تنسحب القوات
الاسرائيليه فجرا كما اقتحمت قوات
اسرائيليه بلده كفردان غرب جنين شمالي
الضفه الغربيه المحتله فجر اليوم ونفذت
حمله اعتقالات النشره مستمره ونتابع فيها
بالمسيرات ليبيا تحارب اوكار مهربين البشر
فتصيب المهاجرين
المياه في نوفا كخوف كاتنحصر لكن الفيضان
يبقى خارج السيطره وروسيا تعلن حاله
الطوارئ في خرسون
بعد مؤشرات غربيه على انطلاق شراره الهجوم
المضاد روسيا تؤكد ان اوكرانيا بدات
هجومها بالفعل
ملفات اقليميه ودوليه على اجنده مباحثات
بلينكن في السعوديه واشنطن تؤكد قوه
العلاقه بين البلدين
وفي نشرتنا ايضا تقرير خاص الفقر والجوع
وانعدام الامن ثلاثيه تدفع الافغان الى
العيش في الكهوف
احييكم من جديد شهدت مشاهدينا شوارع مدينه
ام درمان اشتباكات عنيفه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني في قاعده السلاح
المهندسين الرئيسيه التابعه للجيش وذلك
بحسب ما نقل شهود عيان هذا وتقول لجانب
المقاومه في الاحياء ان اللصوص وبعضهم
قادمون من العاصمه ينهبون احياء الخرطوم
ويسرقون السيارات ويكسرون الخزائن ويحتلون
المنازل في الاثناء حذر القيادي في قوى
الحريه الحريه والتغيير حذر المجلس
المركزي ياسر عرمان من تغيير نوعي في
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع وذلك
مع استخدام الاسلحه الثقيله والمدفعيه
بعيده المدى في مناطق ماهوله بالسكان
وارتفاع وتيره المواجهات بين القوات على
الارض وذلك يزيد من الضحايا المدنيين
وتدمير البنيه التحديه وتدمير منازل
المواطنين وقال عثمان ان هناك مخاوف من
طرح تقسيم السودان حل مشددا على ان الحرب
تهدد وحده السودان وتهدد تماسك المجتمع
وتنذر بانهيار الدوله معنا من ام درمان
الصحفي في مكتب العربيه في السودان شهر
نادر اهلا بك معنا شاهدي اذا استمرار
للاشتباكات واستمرار للوضع الانساني
المتدهور في السودان ما المعلومات الجديده
المتوفره لديك شهد تفضل
صباح الخير فاطمه ونحن نجهز لهذا المباشر
اعاده ذوي القصف المدفعي بشكل مكثف استهدف
مناطق لم نتبين ان كانت هي شرقيه مدينه ام
درمان او مدينه الخرطوم بحري الواقع على
الضفه الاخرى من نهر النيل اليوم بدا اقل
حده في اشتباكاته وتحديدا هنا في مدينه ام
درمان ولكن بدات وتيره الاشتباكات ترتفع
بشكل ملحوظ بدانا نستمع الى اصوات الاطلاق
نار اصوات من اسلحه خفيفه كذلك عاود القصف
المدفعي الطيران الحربي حلق قبل حوالي
ساعه والنصف اخر بي ام درمان و اجتمع
الناس هناك انفجارات هائله كذلك في جنوبي
انظرومان على في منطقه ما بعد منطقه
الفتيحاب في منطقه الصالحه هناك ايضا ظلت
تدور اشتباكات بشكل متقطع وهناك صوت جنوبي
مدينه ام درمان اسخن كذلك بدات تتصاعد من
غربي مدينه الخرطوم اصوات مضادات كانت قد
انطلقتها من عده مناطق في مدينه الخرطوم
ايضا ها في جنوبي هنا في جنوبي مدينه ام
درمان هذا هو المجمل حتى هذه اللحظه يمكن
ان نقول بان اليوم هو اقل حده من يوم امس
اصوات الاشتباكات وذوي القصف ذوي القصف
المدفعي يزداد بشكل ملاحظ خلال الساعتين
الماضيتين
لك من ام درمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه في
السودان شهدي نادر
نبقى في السودان وتحديدا في مستشفياتها
حيث يكون الدواء لا يهدا لا يهدئ الام
المدنيين ماساه جديده كشف عنها وزير الصحه
في ولايه شرق دارفور مع توقف 66% من
المراكز الطبيه القريبه من الاشتباكات عن
العمل اما بسبب القصر او الاخلاء القسري
اضافه الى نقص حاد في المعدات الطبيه
بكافه انواعها والادويه كذلك ما ادى الى
وفاه سته اطفال حديثي الولاده في مستشفى
الضعين بحسب وزير الصحه وفي حين اوضحت
الامم المتحده انها تراقب الوضع عن كثب
وترصد الانتهاكات المستمره في السودان
تجسم المصائب على قلوب الافغانيين اثقلتهم
هموم الجوع والفقر يقول المدنيون ان قواهم
قد خارت فبلادهم تتصدر قائمه الدول الاكثر
تضررا من شبح ازمه الغذاء شبح كان قد
اختفى اذا ما كانت الدوله اولى اهتماما
اكبر بالزراعه وفق خبراء لكن لم يتحقق ذلك
فدروس الزراعه والتنميه اصبح تطبيقها صعبا
في عهد طالبان واظهرت الاحصاءات ان تسعه
من كل عشره اسر تقاسي جوعا مزمنا جوع ينهش
في بطونهم واقتصاد منهار اكثر من نصفهم
يحتاج الى اسعافات طارئه فبحسب معطيات
الامم المتحده اكثر من 28 مليون من اصل
اربعين مليون افغاني بينهم نساء واطفال
يترنحون على شفا موت محدق بسبب نقص
التغذيه
اذا مشاهدينا اين يفر الافغانيون من الفقر
بعد ان عجزوا عن تامين احتياجاتهم وذلك
بعيدا حيث الظلام يلجا المئات من سكان
مقاطعه باميان الى الكهوف كهوف وجدوا فيها
مسكنا لكنه يخلو من ادنى مقومات العيش
نتابع التفاصيل مع مراسل العربيه عبد الله
نادر
في تهتم تم حفره قبل الفي عام تعيش نوريا
الارمله مع اطفالها الثلاثه تقول نوريا ان
زوجها كان مدمنا مخدرات وقد توفي قبل اقل
من عام
ودفعتها الظروف الاقتصاديه الصعبه هي
واسرتها للعيش في هذا الكهف ولا معيل لها
ولاطفالها
منذ ثلاث سنوات وانا اعيش مع اسرتي في هذا
الكهف العيش في الكهف صعب جدا لان
اقتصادنا ضعيف لا نستطيع شراء الحطب
والوقود فصل الشتاء من اصعب الفصول علينا
حيث تنزل الامطار والثلوج وتتساقط الاحجار
من فوق وفي الكهوف عقارب سامه
اسره طاهره ايضا تعيش في كهف اخر ولدى
طاهره اربعه من الاطفال بينهم رضيع ذو شهر
واحد وهو مريض لا ينقطع عن البكاء تقول
طاهره ان اسرتها لجات الى العيش في هذا
الكهف قبل عامين جراء مشاكل اقتصاديه وعدم
قدرتهم على استئجار منزل
مشكلات نواجه مشاكل كثيره فلا نملك منزلا
واقتصادنا هش وضعيف فالمنزل من اساسيات
العيش كما تعرف ومن سعاده المرء امتلاك
المنزل ووجود مصدر رزق ونحن لا نملك لا
منزلا ولا مصدر رزق
عدد هذه الكهوف الاثريه حوالي 14 الف كهف
وعلى الرغم من ادراج هذه المنطقه في قائمه
اليونسكو للتراث الانساني عام 2003 يئن
فيها اطفال رضع واخرون مراهقون لم يروا
واجهه المدرسه يوما في وقت تسعى سلطات في
باميان الى بناء مستوطنه لسكانها يطالب
سكان هذه الكهوف الحكومه الحاليه باتخاذ
خطه اكثر جديه لاخراجهم منها واسكانهم في
بيوت لائقه تحفظ لهم حياه كريمه وتحويل
هذه الكهوف الاثريه الى مكان يزوره
السائحون عبد الاله نادر العربيه من
مقاطعه باميان
بعد اسبوعين من المفاوضات الليبيه في
المغرب فشلا ممثل مجلسي النواب والدوله في
توقيع مسوده قوانين الانتخابات وغادر رئيس
مجلس النواب الليبي عقيل صالح بوزنيقه بعد
خلافات حول بعض بنود مشاريع القوانين
وتركز الخلاف بشكل رئيسي حول شرط التنازل
عن الجنسيه الثانيه للمرشحين للرئاسه
وذكرت مصادر ان عقيل صالح ووفد مجلس
النواب طالبوا بان يكون شرط التنازل عن
الجنسيه الثانيه ضمن شروط الفوز بالرئاسه
وليست ترشحي لها
انتهينا بفضل الله تعالى الى الاتفاق على
كافه نقاط الاختلاف
واصدرنا
وتم سن قانونين القانون الاول قانون يتعلق
بالسلطه التشريعيه وهو
قانون انتخابات مجلس الامه الذي يتكون من
غرفتين
مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ كما تم الاتفاق
على قانون انتخاب رئيس الدوله
وقد كانت الاتفاقات حول النقاط العالقه
كلها تمت بتوافق تام
من جانبه ذكر عضو مجلس النواب الليبي جلال
الشرهيدي ان رئيس مجلس النواب ورئيس مجلس
الدوله سيوقعان او يبتان خلال الايام
المقبله في الاتفاق النهائي بشان قانون
الانتخابات وفق قوله تم التوافق بين لجنتي
لجنه سته زائد سته من مجلس النواب ومجلس
الدوله على
قانون لانتخابات الرئاسه وانتخابات
البرلمان
وننتظر في الايام القادمه
حضور السيد رئيس مجلس النواب ورئيس مجلس
الدوله
التوقيع او
البث في
الاتفاق النهائي في
بخصوص هذا هذا القانون
رحله تتضاضل فيها نسب الحياه عنوانها
مهاجرون ارتحلوا بحثا عن حياه هنا في
ليبيا من شرقها الى غربها حيث تحارب قوات
الجيش او كارت تهريب والاشجار بالمخدرات
والبشر ولكن قد يكون الضحايا مهاجرون فروا
من اعباء الحروب والتشرد الى ترحيل اخر
يتربص بهم او ربما موت على حين غفله بتلك
الطائرات صحيفه
قالت ان هذه الغارات التي تستهدف عصابات
الهجره قد تقتل معها هؤلاء الهاربين ففي
الشرق الليبي احتجز ما يقارب سته الاف
مهاجر يقطعون ويبحرون في ظلمات البحر وفي
منتصف الحالتين قد يترصدون لهم لاعادتهم
الى النقطه الاولى اقصد العذاب الاول وقد
تتقاذفهم الامواج فتبتلعهم بعد ان ظنوا في
البحر امانا
خمسون الفا وصلوا الى ايطاليا وفقا
للحكومه في روما الا ان نحو الفا منهم لم
تكتمل رحلتهم فغرقوا من دون ان يكتبوا
لحياتهم فصلا اخر
[موسيقى]
تراجعات مشاهدينا الليره التركيه بنحو
ثلاثه في المئه لتصل لمستوى قياسي جديد
وتواصل الخسائر التي تتكبدها منذ اعلان
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان تشكيله حكومته
مطلع الاسبوع بعد الانتخابات التي جرت
الشهر الماضي حيث انخفضت الليره التي
تتعرض لضغوط وطلب قوي على العملات
الاجنبيه من نحو 3% الى
22.15% مقابل الدولار لتصل خسائرها بذلك
منذ بدايه العام وحتى الان الى 15% فاصله
خمسه
وافقت المحكمه العليا في الدوله
الاسكندنافيه على تسليم مناصر لحزب العمل
الكردستاني الى تركيا في قرار يلبي شرطا
رئيسيا وضعته انقره للموافقه على انضمام
سوكونلم الى حلف شمال الاطلسي وبحسب صحيفه
صحيفه السويديه فان هذا الرجل صدر بحقه
الحكم بالسجن في تركيا وبعدما حصل على
اطلاق سراح مشروط انتقل الى الاقامه في
السويد لكن السلطات في ستوكهولم اوقفته
بناء على طلب من النيابه العامه التركيه
مؤكده انه سيكون اول مؤيد لحزب العمال
الكردستاني تسلمه السويد الى تركيا
قتل شخصان واصيب خمسه اخرون على الاقل
جراء اطلاق نار خارج مدرسه ثانويه في
مدينه ورتشمنت في ولايه فيرجينيا
الامريكيه ووقع الهجوم اثناء حفل تخرج
وذكرت الشرطه ان منفذه يبلغ من العمر 19
عاما ووجهت اليه اتهامات بالقتل ولم تكشف
السلطات عن الدافع وراء هذا الاطلاق
في نهايه النشر نذكر بالعناوين
المياه في نوفاكا خوف كاتنحصر لكن الفيضان
يبقى خارج السيطره وروسيا تعلن حاله
الطوارئ في خرسون
بعد مؤشرات غربيه على انطلاق شراره الهجوم
المضاد روسيا تؤكد ان اوكرانيا بدات
هجومها بالفعل
ملفات اقليميه ودوليه على اجنده مباحثات
بلينكن في السعوديه
تؤكد قوه العلاقه بين البلدين
وكان في نشرتنا ايضا تقرير خاص عن الفقر
والجوع وانعدام الامن ثلاثيه تدفع الافغان
الى العيش في الكهوف
الزميل نايف الاحمر معكم على راس الساعه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات